pratiquer le français est effectivement
à découvrir de nouvelles connaissances
d'économie politique le monde de
l'entreprise pendant nos trois vendu à
l'origine de l'idée cette enseignante
chercheuse en économie vient d'en
résumer le principe est l'objectif
améliorer son français
les étudiants de cette classe
particulière ont entre 22 et 43 ans tous
ont suivi des études supérieures dans
leur pays d'origine
comme cette jeune femme syrienne cette
étudiante en 3e année de la littérature
française quand c'était hélas que cette
cave et la guerre ton qu'on était obligé
de partir je suis resté en turquie un an
et après je suis venu ici avec mon mari
et ma petite fille tous les cours seront
dispensés bénévolement par les
professeurs de l'école
en outre les réfugiés pourront également
s'appuyer sur les étudiants les
étudiants vont être vous accompagner sur
ces trois mois ils vont être avec vous
pour la découverte de dijon si vous
connaissez pas par exemple pour
retravailler un cv pour passer du temps
avec vous tout simplement sera un peu
vos points de repères par rapport à leur
niveau de formation les réfugiés
souffrent d'un réel des classements avec
des offres de travail très éloignés des
compétences acquises dans leur pays
qu'attendent-ils précisément de cette
formation d'abord pour améliorer ma
langue française anglais aussi et pour
bien s'intégrer dans la société et pour
essayer de ouvrir des portes pour que je
puisse travailler dans ça c'était
j'espère que c'est bien c'est
de commencer de nouvelles vivre pour moi
pour complot et mes études et aussi
chercher un travail
aider les réfugiés à relancer leur
projet professionnel
les faire bénéficier d'un solide réseau
d'entreprise voilà donc à quoi peut
servir cette formation généreuse et
original